[Music]  can we talk about this dress the Met  Gala perfect tell me everything thank  you it's about the Sistine Chapel Ariana  wanted a reference to religion but she  didn't want to be literal  hence the beautiful hairpiece if she's  wearing it's a total drift off religion  but in the most stylish fashion-forward  way and she's young and beautiful who  can wear anything we missed you welcome  back song the performance on Fallon  prison life tell me how you're feeling  being back in the game  thank you um I'm feeling great this is  my first met I'm very excited and I'm so  happy to be Madeira to be wearing the  Sistine Chapel back by Michelangelo and  it's the Last Judgement and I'm excited  because it's beautiful and there's such  an exciting time for you as a woman and  an artist what does it mean to you to  release new music and your fans and  everyone loves it so much oh my god it's  a gift and it's a joy and I'm so  grateful to be back  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]